hallo herr doktor shell selbstgebaute
klimaanlage oder ventilator wie können
wir uns denn in so einer heißen nach der
jetzt vor uns liegt abkühlen
also eine selbstgebaute klimaanlage ist
schon eine gute idee
das sollte man ruhig ausprobieren
ventilator auch einsetzen denn wir haben
in deutschland ja keine kultur der
klimaanlagen wie in südlichen ländern
das einzige problem bei der selbst
gebauten klimaanlage ist wenigstens betz
stelle könnte ich mich erwartet wenn der
zug zu starkes erkälten oder es kann
mich irren durch das ventilatoren
geräusch aber ansonsten ist es auf jeden
fall eine gute idee
und wie sollte ich mich denn vor so
einer heißen nacht ernähren damit ich
auch gut in den schlaf finden also das
wichtigste ist dass der menschliche
körper ja die hitze regulation über die
flüssigkeit machen wir schwitzen das
heißt wir brauchen viel mehr flüssigkeit
wenn es heiß ist als normal das heißt
ich muss viel trinken trinken heißt
allerdings nicht unbedingt alkohol weil
er mehr denn außer dem körper entzieht
als dazu führt wir sollten ungesüßte
getränke zu uns nehmen mineralwasser tee
es vielleicht auch mal kaffee und so
weiter oder auch ein alkoholfreies
hefeweizen das sind alles sachen die gut
sind und davon sollten wir schon
reichlich uns nehmen damit die
wärmeregulation ist körpers auf gut
funktioniert sonst kann es zu
kreislaufproblemen
wie kann ich denn das verhindern und
haben sie vielleicht auch noch weitere
gesundheitstipps jetzt nicht nur für die
nacht sondern auch für die kommenden
heißen tage
also man sollte auf jeden fall die
direkte sonneneinstrahlung die alle
sorten vermeiden
dann lieber gut mütze oder sowas tragen
luftige kleidung nicht zu wenig kleidung
aber luftige und eher kühle räume
aufsuchen schatten aufsuchen usw
körperliche anstrengung nur so weit wie
man sie gewohnt ist und wie sie auch gut
tut so weidmann schwindel verspielt ist
es zu viel
wer so gewohnt ist auf beiden ironman zu
laufen der hat sich kein problem mit dem
wetter jetzt aber wer das nicht gewohnt
ist der sollte im zweifel
die joggingstrecke dann doch verzichten
und essen angeht
jetzt zum beispiel wichtig dass man eher
leichte kost zu sich nimmt wenn es nicht
so viel appetit tage dann ist das okay
da sollte ich den folgen und auch gar
nicht so viel essen lieber mehr
flüssigkeit mit dem was ist denn mit
kindern und besonders mit kleinen
kindern worauf muss ich da achten bei
diesem hitze wetter also kinder und auch
ältere menschen sind tatsächlich in
gewisser weise risiko